I told fritzy to reach out for uh maybe
Bryan Cranston to join us and I know
Bryan is busy he's on Broadway doing
Network it's the movie he's doing
Network on Broadway and I said could you
check in and see if Bryan can join us I
just want to ask him if it's true that
Vince Gilligan is going to do maybe a
movie version of Breaking Bad the
Albuquerque Journal had that report I
saw it in variety today and I thought
man maybe who could we ask - you know
maybe confirm or deny that and Bryan
Cranston kind enough to join us Bryan
thanks for joining us
can we get we get right to the story
where are you right now by the way I'm
in my dressing room at the Belasco
Theatre in New York rehearsing for
Network fantastic play and when is that
going to be when does it debut we we
start performing this Saturday night and
then we run all the way through March
so hopefully you come I would love to
okay would you want to know if we're in
the audience would that affect your
performance no I'll still throw a spiral
really would you will you try harder if
you know we're there like act better
you know we're there if one of your guys
is sitting in the front row by the way
if Christy is sitting in the front row I
might go over and and and and do one of
my speeches in front of him and it might
expect to rate him a little bit it would
be fun no I wouldn't know it doesn't
bother me knowing who's in the audience
it really doesn't know you get kind of
locked in for actors it's kind of a kin
to the locker room before you're it's
game time and you're you sit down in it
you gather all your senses and you're
ready to perform and so they go out
there with you know thousands and
thousands of people in the and the
stands and in millions on TV and and
they have to play the game they have to
get used to that they have to
in some how in some way desensitize
themselves to the audience wait wait are
you doing that because you left to put
it in sports terms because you don't
think I can understand what you're
[Laughter]
honest I always like it when people are
around me and they go okay
in your world no no no I can understand
other worlds besides my world of sports
all right let's get to the headline here
is there going to be a movie version of
Breaking Bad I'm sorry
yes it there appears to be a movie
version of Breaking Bad but I honestly
have not even read the script so I've
got mr. Lu I have not gotten the script
okay I have not read the script and so
there's question or whether or not we
would even see Walter White in this
movie are you how are you interested to
play Walter White in the movie I would I
would absolutely because he's Vince
Gilligan you asked me to do it sure
absolutely
yeah he's a genius and it's a great
story
and there's a lot of people who felt
that they wanted to see some kind of
completion to some of these storylines
that were left open and this idea from
what I'm told get into those like at
least a couple of the characters who
[Music]
were not completed as far as their their
journey okay about that words carefully
I'll try okay I'm trying
so you haven't gotten a script you
haven't been content
has been I'm told you've been punted
okay has bends elegant talk to you yes
three downpour to go super bit and and
but I honestly haven't read it yet okay
I don't know if there's an appearance or
how what kind of appearance flashback
slash forward I have no clue but I'm
excited about it because it's Breaking
Bad and it was you know the greatest
professional period of my life and I'm
wait to see all those people again you
see even if I just come by to visit is
it five years since you were Walter
White is that the last time 2013 it's
over it's like yeah five and a half
years since we finished production of
Breaking Bad can you believe it but did
you move it on but to have that break
and then go back is that a good thing or
bad like it would it be easy to go back
as Walter White right now it would be
you know it's one of those things where
where it never opened up a case or an
old suitcase and you find a sweater that
you once wore any like oh look at this I
remember this and you put it on suddenly
kind of flashes back to that time and I
think if I put on his clothes and shaved
my head and put the glasses on and maybe
the the Heisenberg hat I think those
talismans could just send me back there
quickly almost like a the evocative song
sends you back into your memories it's
still you you know the one quote that
you always get how often you asked about
that one quote about being the danger I
am the danger I am the danger I'm asked
all the time about Breaking Bad and I'm
happy to answer it because it's it was a
great time for me but you know I move on
I'm doing this play I do other movies
and things like that so
it's very fortunate I am the danger that
sums up that's that sums up breaking but
I told my wife I said and she just
started watching I said there's a quote
that will sum it up and then watch just
watch the quote and then she and she
goes okay so she just started to watch
Breaking Bad so I'll let you know are
you watching it with her no no no I
watched it
hi finished it a long time ago but I
just said you don't care to watch it
again I know how it ends a bonding
opportunity if it is you know my my kids
and I love to talk about meth and you
know chemistry teachers it's great
hey good luck with the play I promise
you I'm gonna come in and see you and
it's Network and this was the the
brilliant movie that Howard Beale was
the star of network and of course Brian
being one of the great actors of our
generation you'll kill I'm sure you'll
slay this but I I'm gonna come in soon I
think I promise please do and and we
will make sure it will send some
invitations out to you guys I'd love to
have you come to see it it's really a
very poignant play too especially in our
times well hopefully we'll cross paths
here soon and thanks again for joining
us on short notice and we'll hopefully
talk soon thank you
that's Bryan Cranston for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]